oggi video molto particolare in italia
andremo a provare la coca cola
trasparente anche delta coca cola clear
cioè in realtà si chiama coca cola clima
che si è venuta questa idea allora un po
troppo facile così youtube mia pastre
consigliati un video una persona super
si chiama marco togni che prova la coca
cola clear appunto perché se non sbaglio
lui vive in giappone più è troppo
divertente su presentate insomma una
magra buoni
mi ha convinto dovrebbe intendere
qualcosa perché è però molto convincente
io purtroppo mi vedo cuore ma l'ordinata
su ebay
arriva infatti direttamente d'altro pone
è come caso messo poco ad arrivare fino
a volte per curioso di provarla vedere
come e poi abbiamo anche una
bottiglietta di coca cola normale così
andiamo si deve se stiamo entrambe
vediamo se c'è qualche differenza
poi magari potremmo rischiare insomma
avrà qualche differenza del vapore
mentre vediamo da direttamente da o
tattica e per la dogana è stata
dichiarata come un valore di 1.000 yen
perché non ho idea di quanto siano mille
year in euro a 7 euro e 70 semplice tesi
giri 17 euro e 77
voi siete sapete quanti sono mille euro
1.000 yen di euro quasi tutto per me
come se è giusto comunque andiamo ad
aprirla arriva direttamente da oltre a
tanta istinti ott h ok andiamo ad
aprirla speriamo che sia intatta
oddio castrato chi non utilizza l'acqua
i pezzi da nova per maroni ma non è che
il lavoro in acqua
a me sembrava qua problema d'italia il
polline a me c'è affari come con la
chicca 0 kcal più per cento di qualcosa
giapponese da ok c'è scritto con ha un
partenza se conoscete il giapponese che
cosa c'è scritto quasi conosciuto il
giapponese traducete nei commenti per
favore c'è scritto un per cento di
questa cosa e poi dietro ci sono gli
altri ingredienti ingredienti in
giapponese
ovviamente un'idea che cosa dicano
comunque sembra veramente una bottiglia
d'acqua anche per come si muove
beh ce n'è sicuramente di meglio dopo
cioè questa comunque la dimensione è
simile ma sembra che in quella clear ce
ne sia un po di meno agitate entrambe
fanno le polle vediamo poi quando
andiamo aprile si scoppia rimbalzano beh
queste non sono una che faccia un po
meno bene di un po più leggero sembra
l'acqua minerale dico lo accomunerà le
ferrarelle chiediamo la ditta andare sì
questi però mar meno male che questa
zero calorie quindi ci sarà il
dolcificante model risultano invece
sente c'è un'antica muro mi sembra che
poi si rischia di meno ma non so se
forse la forma della bottiglia e a
questo vado fino a nuovo grazie the
pronti ora andiamo ad hazard ok pronti
ad aprirla
guardate che affiggono il con traffica
coca cola nera e coca cola trasparente
run cup piccola bianca tipo multi core
pronta la relatrice gli infissi
c'è paura
oddio ok per il resto non ha fatto
moltissima schiuma sentiamo l'odore
prima
sembra di coca cola contatto limone
l'odore per roma raccontiamo alla fine
spray è certo da citare un bene a un po
vediamo
ok sì questa sembra che ci sia un po una
sorta di retro anche se il retrogusto il
retro autore che fu di limone non
sembrate non sono i dalle sensazioni di
chimico cioè di ancora più chimica 11
dove ricreato non proprio limone l'odore
della nemone ricrea molti pur il
creatore della piccola cucina
andiamo a passare l'appetito
[Musica]
ok rischio ne fa parecchia ripensate per
me è andata via subito
vediamo la differenza con la coca cola
normale per quanto riguarda la stipula
beh sì alla fine mi guarda
ok tramvia testare
salvi come la folla tipo la coca cola
zero
non mi ricordo perché non mi piace un
attacco la collega 0 dai con visto che 0
kcal potrebbe essere appunto per quel
motivo la taglia che è stata invece
dello zucchero aspartame dolcificante
facciamo sempre
sì infatti nissa che è molto simile alla
coca cola dai esco forse che ne pensi
sembra la tesco nostro perdono senza
stessi se stessi sempre andare tutto
virtus che farò non riusciva perché ma
quand'è che dopo un po ancora il robusto
di coca cola come ti avessero vinto dopo
questo malore
non so perché ma mi è sembrato mie
qualsiasi intanto dalla pepsi
leggermente parte rimane come dichiarato
di leggere il sapore della coca cola e
calorie
comunque vada ora a vela con carmona
questo
sento meglio il sapore se avete più
piazzata scherzato durante il viaggio
sì questa sembra una forza di diet coke
pista sprite si fa di coca cola con
questo mondo in calcola non etico un
qualcosa di completamente diverso da
umbri coca cola solo che fa di coca cola
senza zucchero totti è incredibile di
dire stampone della coca cola bevendo
molto trasparente che ne pensi vedendo
la differenza nel senso anche resta
sempre coca cola vero è un pochettino
meno saporita il bravissimo bene questo
corto trasparente e sentieri gusto di
coca cola è stranissimo
ora andiamo a mischiare un po di coca
cola normale con la coca cola acli e
trasparente vediamo un po
per riuscire del tutto del 4 scardino
certo è diventata la coca cola o più
chiara passato che scrivete
ho voluto re si sente più quello della
coca cola tia che della copertura romane
che strano aperto anche il sapore ora
sento solo quello praticamente sembra
dai praticamente ha preso il sapore solo
della casa trasparente è diventata cosa
con la trasparente in modo che nato come
con la normale si vendono tutti parigi
click
quindi eccola qua allora vi assicuro che
non è stata sostituita non ho mai se
nessuna nessun acqua frizzante dei drone
sprite è quello originale potete
guardare anche qui potete vedere anche
dall etichetta che quella originale
allora ne lascia un po qua nella
bottiglia perché potete decidere voi che
cosa farci questa scuola trasparente nei
prossimi di che se volete che ci passano
qualche challenge con conta volete che
la moschiano che premi il prime dieci
vie cosa vorrebbe che cosa volete che
mischiano con questa coca cola finire
video sto pensando magari prendiamola
facebook è solo mia ma perché pagare
questa è proprio uguale andata ieri
perché con questa di coca cola però
senza zucchero voi vorreste provarla
questa cover mola mi piacerebbe provarla
o non vi piace presente che non che non
sia buona fateci sapere nei commenti
ma che si sapesse c'è qualcos'altro
distante volete che testiamo dal
giappone o da altre parti del mondo o
cartier banda scriveteci pure nei
commenti cosa questa che volete che ci
sentiamo mi raccomando lasciato bel live
secondo video se volete vedere altri
video test e ora mila sono qua 4
sterline su cui potete cliccare per
vedere i prossimi video cliccate su
quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao